Your first big film "Joint Security Area" directed by Park Chan-wook,...
...did you ever think it was going to be as big as what it was?
No, I don't think so, because nobody estimates about the result when they're filming it.
Of course, I didn't too. So,...
...we're surprised by the amount of the audience and...
...that movie made me so popular and famous in Korea.
So, I was really thankful to Mr. Park.
The film was based on tension between North and South Korea.
And I believe it was the first film that portrayed North Koreans in a good way.
How did you feel being involved in such a project?
That's the point that I liked.
It's not about the ideology or something like that.
It's not political things.
That movie tells about the human.
Do you think it changed the way that South Koreans view their neighbors?
Do they look differently at North Korea because of your movie?
Maybe that movie infected the people.
Of course, because it was a huge success.
So, most of the people watched it and...
That movie is based on the truth, so people would say,...
...people would think, "They're the same humans like us."
Do you think that there will be reunification? In your lifetime?
Personally, I hope so.
Yeah, it could happen I think.
Following the success of "Joint Security Area",...
...Byung-hun went on to star in the critically acclaimed "A Bittersweet Life"...
...and "The Good, the Bad, the Weird" which premiered at Cannes in 2008.
But as Byung-hun himself points out, his best work is yet to come.
I understand that you are your harshest critic,...
...that you're never fully happy with your performance.
Why is that?